salut toi
je ne suis pas un charmant libraire à
New York ni un vendeur à Los Angeles ni
à Marie aimant dans une banlieue chic
non ça c'est fini
permettez-moi de me présenter
j'ai acquis un certain raffinement
traversant l'Atlantique et vivre à
Londres m'a permis d'enterrer le passé
si je puis dire
l'amour à sens unique les heures à
attendre c'est derrière moi non cette
fois je vais me concentrer sur
l'université et l'enseignement quant à
mes activités extrascolaires elles
resteront strictement professionnel
il faut garder du temps pour échanger
avec des collègues qui partagent vos
valeurs malheureusement avoir des amis
haut placé implique des fréquenter des
gens qui veulent gravir l'échelle de la
réussite parfois pour certains c'est la
chute et la mort sociale peut-être
ont-ils été poussé
[Musique]
mais alors
par qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]